في بروكسل صدق قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي على
خطه تهدف الى تزويد اوكرانيا بمليون قذيفه
خلال 12 شهرا وكان وزراء الدفاع والخارجيه
الاوروبيون قد وافقوا قبل ذلك على خطه
بقيمه ملياري يورو لتزويد اوكرانيا بمليون
قذيفه مدفعيه تقتطع من مخزونات دولهم
واكد الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي سيسرع تزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخيره والصواريخ ماكرون اضاف في ختام
القمه الاوروبيه في بروكسل ان القمه جددت
دعمها لاوكرانيا كلما تطلب الامر ذلك
مشيرا الى تشديد على ضروره عدم الافلات من
العقاب لمرتكب جرائم الحرب
من جانبه قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ان الاسلحه المقدمه الى اوكرانيا
والمتخصصين الاجانب الذين وصلوا معها هدف
مشروع للقوات الروسيه وحذر من ان عواقب
اصطدام اقوى جيوش العالم ستكون رهيبه ولم
يستبعد ذهب القوات الروسيه الى كييف او
الفيف في اوكرانيا وقال ان هناك حاجه الى
مناطق منزوعه السلاح حول المناطق التي
سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه داخل اوكرانيا
فيما يتعلق باستمرار العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه امل ان لا تتوقعوا مني الاجابه على
هذا السؤال لانه سيكون خطا دعونا لا نتسرع
لا يمكن استبعاد اي شيء هنا اذا كانت هناك
حاجه للوصول الى كيف فيجب الذهاب الى كييف
او الى الفيف فهذا يعني انه يجب الذهاب
الى الفيب من اجل القضاء على هذا المرض